hinter uns wir haben gesehen dass nach
den attentaten von paris-nizza und wien
die solidaritätsbekundungen auf
europäischer ebene sehr groß waren wir
sehen aber auch dass die solistische
bedrohungen und die gefahr die vom
extremismus ausgeht alle europäischen
länder betrifft wir sehen dass hier alle
länder betroffen sind der terrorismus
habe zugeschlagen und zwar mehrfach in
allen ländern paris berlin london madrid
barcelona kopenhagen stockholm wien und
so weiter deswegen müssen wir uns auf
eine gemeinsame koordinierte und
schnelle antwort seinigen das war
gegenstand unserer diskussionen wir
werden in den kommenden wochen weiter
arbeiten und werden mit all unseren
kollegen in der ratssitzung vom dezember
ebenfalls darüber diskutieren unsere
verschiedenen stimmen uns wirklich
besser zu koordinieren um gegen den
terrorismus zu kämpfen gegen die
radikalisierung und das mit vielen
gezielten maßnahmen ich danke für die
beiträge der niederlande auch mit dem
mit österreich haben wir seit mehreren
jahren in diesem bereich zusammen
gearbeitet
weiter tun die bestehenden maßnahmen
tatsächlich umsetzen und zwar die
maßnahmen die wir seit dem attentat im
jahr 2015 in europa aufgelegt haben wir
heute ist der zehnte november das ist
drei tage vor dem gedenktag vor dem 5
um diese bedenken uns alle schwer
getroffen haben
aber da diese ereignisse haben auch dazu
geführt dass wir hier gemeinsam einige
maßnahmen zusammenstellen konnten nun
geht es darum bemühen diese maßnahmen
konsequent umzusetzen zum beispiel die
interoperabilität von datenbanken die
verknüpfung unserer daten über eine
zusammenarbeit unserer
sicherheitsdienste auch an den
außengrenzen zum beispiel auch die
nutzung der pnr register um eine lücke
zu schließen in der sicherheitskette
denn jede lücke in der sicherheitskette
zum beispiel in den informationssystemen
auch nur in einem einzigen unserer
mitgliedstaaten ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko für alle unsere
mitgliedstaaten wir und nun müssen also
dafür sorgen dass diese maßnahmen
tatsächlich zu ende gebracht werden und
konkret umgesetzt und angewendet werden
die das wir diskutiert haben ist die
entschlossenheit mit der wir gegen
terroristische propaganda und hassreden
im internet vorgehen wollen
internet ist ein raum der freiheit aber
diese freiheit riskieren wenn es auf
sicherheit gibt und es darf nicht ein
schlupfwinkel sein für diejenigen die
gegen unsere werte kämpfen versuchen
diese zu untergraben
deswegen setzen wir uns dafür ein die
verordnung über die absetzung von
terroristischen inhalt innerhalb einer
stunde in den kommenden wochen auch
verabschiedet wird
die arbeiten hatten wir damals schon
begonnen und wünschen uns dass diese von
so einem ergebnis gebracht werden
deswegen werden wir ende dezember die
sogenannte dsa richtlinie verabschieden
die eben wie gesagt darauf abzielt
terroristische inhalte zu löschen
wir müssen des weiteren an
eine reform der schengen-regeln arbeiten
das bedeutet nicht dass wir hier die
themen verwechseln terrorismus kampf
gegen den terrorismus oder illegale
migration das attentat von nizza hatte
er hier ein deutliches hervorgebracht
wir müssen also den schengen raum
grundsätzlich überarbeiten aber wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die
freizügigkeit tatsächlich unter
vorbehalt dass eben die außengrenzen
entsprechend geschützt werden
denn mit dem schengen raumes kam auch
das versprechen einher die außengrenzen
zu sichern und dieses versprechen wurde
nicht ausreichend eingehalten und wir
können unsere grenzen nicht weiterhin
offen halten wenn wir nicht in der lage
sind wenn wir die schengen regeln nicht
grundlegend reformieren wir müssen diese
reform durchführen damit schengen raum
der sicherheit ist das bedeutet dass wir
die außengrenzen der europäischen union
die stärken und besser verteidigen
müssen das wird die funktionsweise der
schengen regeln besser kontrollieren und
umsetzen müssen
schengen raums muss regelmäßig
überarbeitet werden unter
berücksichtigung sämtlicher die
politischen die davon betroffen sind und
ich hoffe dass wir bald einen
tatsächlich einen echten sicherheitsrat
werden einsetzen wir haben dieses
reformprojekt ausführlich diskutiert
haben das mit und kollegen geteilt sind
sehr zuversichtlich dass wir
fortschritte bergen erreichen können
denn den schengen-raum zur schengen
regeln zu reformieren bedeutet dass wir
die freiheit genießen werden können aber
auch sicherheit
ich danke all meinen kollegen auf dem
kanzler
und uns darin unterstützt die
europäische reaktion auf grund dieser
bedrohungen mit zu bearbeiten
sehr geehrte damen und herren
geschätzter herr präsident lieber
manuell ich möchte mich zunächst einmal
für die einladung nach paris bedanken
auch danke sagen für unser gutes
arbeitsgespräch und ich habe die
konferenz mit angela merkel mag rote
ursula von der leyen und shell als sehr
wertvoll empfunden
mit dem ziel gemeinsam zu besprechen was
wir tun können um europa noch sicherer
und somit auch wieder lebenswerter zu
machen
österreich ist in der letzten woche wie
viele andere länder zuvor opfer eines
sehr brutalen islamistischen terror
angriffs geworden es war ein schock
erlebnis für die bundeshauptstadt wien
aber für unser ganzes land
und es war natürlich dramatische stunden
die wir hier erlebt haben ich möchte an
dieser stelle aber auch ein großes danke
sagen für die solidarität die wir in
diesen stunden genauso erleben durften
und das war das sehr positive von einem
anderen mann angefangen über viele
andere staats und regierungschefs ist
uns nicht nur solidarität bekundet
worden sondern was auch sehr gut
funktioniert hat war dass wir innerhalb
von wenigen stunden
in manchen fällen sogar innerhalb von
wenigen minuten das
unterstützungsangebot all unsere
nachbarstaaten von deutschland
angefangen bekommen haben was den
einsatz ihrer spezialeinheiten betrifft
das war gott sei dank nicht notwendig
diese unterstützung abzurufen aber es
war trotzdem schön zu sehen wie robust
doch die europäische zusammenarbeit der
polizei der spezialeinheiten ist wenn es
darauf ankommt und ein anschlag
vielleicht von der dimension her noch
größer ist dass das was wir erleben
mussten
ich glaube der terroranschlag in
österreich in frankreich in vielen
anderen ländern zeigt auch jedes mal
aufs neue
dass die maßnahmen die wir schon lange
einfordern auch notwendiger weise
umgesetzt werden müssen
und ich kann alle von emanuel makro
angesprochenen punkte unterstützen und
möchte drei punkte vielleicht noch etwas
besonders vertiefen beziehungsweise
bekräftigen das erste thema wir haben
eine ständige gefahr
wir haben tausende von terror ist
weiters die entweder den kampfeinsatz in
syrien im irak für den usa über lebt
haben und zurückgekehrt sind oder die
gar nicht durchgekommen sind weil sie
irgendwo bei der ausreise gestoppt
wurden viele von denen sind im gefängnis
einige sind schon freigelassen und die
traurige wahrheit ist die masse derer
die im gefängnis ist wird in den
nächsten jahren freigelassen werden
das sind tickende zeitbomben und wenn
wir unser aller freiheit schützen wollen
dann müssen wir die freiheit dieser
menschen einschränken es braucht meiner
meinung nach ein robusteres vorgehen
gegenüber den gefährdern in ganz europa
weil diese terroristen auch keine
grenzen kennen und daher egal wo sie
gerade sind eine bedrohung für uns alle
darstellen
zum zweiten möchte ich das thema
unterstützen des schutzes der
europäischen außengrenzen
wir alle sind froh in einem europa ohne
grenzen nach innen leben zu dürfen aber
wir werden das nur aufrecht erhalten
können wenn unsere außengrenzen
funktionieren das betrifft das thema der
migration
das betrifft aber natürlich auch
sicherheitsfragen wie die frage wer ist
überhaupt in europa wer reist ein
wer reist aus wenn wir es nicht schaffen
dass überall an der schengengrenze zu
gewährleisten
dann ist das europa ohne grenzen nach
ihnen langfristig in gefahr
und das glaube ich müssen wir alle
verhindern und zum dritten punkt
es gibt hinter dem terror eine
ideologische basis das ist der
islamismus das ist der politische islam
und den müssen wir auf allen ebenen
bekämpfen schalte schäfer gestern in
wien und hat das thema ausbildung von
imamen angesprochen dass ich für ganz
relevante achte grundsätzlich auch
finanzierungsfragen von vereinen und
auch problematischen institutionen in
diesem zusammenhang und natürlich das
große thema radikalisierung im internet
denn im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
findet die radikalisierung des verführen
von jungen menschen ja nicht nur in
hinterzimmern und moscheen statt sondern
es findet natürlich auch im internet
statt
und wenn es uns nicht gelingt diese
ideologische basis hinter dem terror zu
bekämpfen
dann wird es immer wieder
terroranschläge geben denn der
politische islam die radikalisierung im
hintergrund das ist das gift das ist der
nährboden für den terrorismus
in diesem sinne freue ich mich dass wir
uns heute schon auf einige punkte in
diesem zusammenhang verständigen konnten
und halte es für sinnvoll dass am
freitag die innenminister darüber
beraten und danke auch fall michelle und
seiner von der leyen dass dieses thema
für dezember für den europäischen rat
aufgegriffen werden soll
denn ich glaube viele der maßnahmen die
wir setzen müssen sind schon seit
einiger zeit bekannt jetzt geht es darum
dass wir diese gemeinsam umsetzen und
auf den boden bringen vielen dank an ein
beteiligten noch einmal für die
solidarität in der letzten woche die für
uns eine sehr prägende und schwierige
war aber auch für den gemeinsamen willen
hier voranzukommen
massih wassey meter nach ihren kanzler
frau bundeskanzlerin angela merkel dass
wir uns weiter um die sonne
zusammengefunden haben um über die
schrecklichen und entsetzlichen
anschläge in paris nizza und wien zu
sprechen
wir hatten ja auch in dresden eine
erfahrung mit einem islamistischen
terroristen und wir wissen dass dies
anschläge auf unsere freie gesellschaft
auf unsere art zu leben sind und der
versuch unternommen wird furcht und
angst zu sehen aber wir stellen dem und
das war heute die gemeinsame haltung
unser entschlossenes eintreten für die
freiheitliche demokratische grundordnung
dagegen und werden uns sowohl jeweils in
unseren ländern aber auch eben
europäisch dafür einsetzen
ich weiß wie die menschen in frankreich
und österreich mit gelitten haben und
auch die angehörigen sind in unseren
gedanken der opfer und das möchte ich
auch von deutscher seite hier heute noch
einmal ausdrücken
es geht hier nicht darüber waren wir uns
auch einig um eine auseinandersetzung
zwischen dem islam und dem christentum
zum beispiel sondern es geht darum dass
das demokratische gesellschaftsmodell
sich mit terroristischen und
antidemokratischen verhalten
auseinandersetzen muss und dies mit
grosser aufrichtigkeit und entschiedener
stärke wir verurteilen jede art von
religiösem hass von terrorismus und ich
freue mich dass auch die innenminister
am freitag das thema der
terrorismusbekämpfung auf die
tagesordnung des innenminister rates
setzen werden und dass wir dann im
dezember auf die systeme auch noch
einmal zurückkommen was haben wir an
maßnahmen
in der hand wir müssen erst einmal das
umsetzen was wir schon miteinander
gesprochen haben dass mit einige dinge
noch eine arbeit ich will an das exit
entry system oder entry exit system im
schengen-raum erinnern dass 2022 fertig
sein soll
das ist dringend notwendig dass wir
wissen wer bei uns rein kommt aber auch
wissen wer wieder den schengen raum
verlässt und wir müssen das auch wissen
für die länder mit denen der visafreien
reiseverkehr haben und deshalb ist das
system eben auch in diesem zusammenhang
wichtig das soll 2023 fertig sein
alles was man an beschleunigungs
möglichkeiten hat muss man nutzen
wir wollen natürlich doppelstrukturen
vermeiden aber wir müssen da wo
grenzübergreifendes handeln notwendig
ist auch agieren deshalb für die
deutsche ratspräsidentschaft noch die
verordnung zur verbreitung zum
verhinderung der verbreitung
terroristischer inhalte im internet
fertig stellen die ist im trialog mit
dem europäischen parlament und ich hoffe
dass wir hier ein kompromiss finden der
einerseits schnelles handeln möglich
macht andererseits auch
verfassungsfestes handeln ich begrüße
ausdrücklich dass die kommission das
thema terrorismusbekämpfung in den
nächsten monaten noch auf dem auf der
agenda hat dass dazu auch neue
überprüfungen des funktionierens des
schengenraums beinhaltet sind und glaube
dass uns das auch noch einmal
voranbringen wird
dritter punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
das ist die frage wie gehen wir mit
menschen anderer religionen in unseren
ländern um mit menschen mit
migrationshintergrund wir suchen in
deutschland für die bekämpfung des
terrorismus sehr bewusst auch die
kontakt zu islamischen organisationen
und haben eine so genannte
islamkonferenz die beständig takt und
bestimmte themen auf die tagesordnung
setzt gerade heute hat die islam
konferenz wieder gepackt und sich mit
der ausbildung von imamen beschäftigt
schauen michael hat darauf hingewiesen
wie wichtig das ist dass wir das in
allen europäischen ländern selber machen
die haben islamische studiengänge an
deutschen universitäten und dieses thema
halte ich für ein sehr sehr wichtiges um
sozusagen auch unsere grundgesetzliche
ordnung
von anfang an sehr deutlich zu machen
und ich setze mich dafür ein dass wir
auch mit islamischen ländern über den
kampf den gemeinsamen kampf gegen den
terrorismus sprechen und dafür auch die
kontakte suchen wir haben das in den
letzten tagen sowohl shell als auch ich
als auch in hongkong gemacht und das
werden wir auch weiter tun und so haben
wir auch eine gesellschaftliche
dimension nicht nur eine strafrechtliche
justizielle sondern auch eine
gesellschaftliche diskussion und
dimension dieses kampfes gegen den
terrorismus ich bedanke mich für die
initiative bei euch im mangel und bei
der sebastian für die ergriffen hat und
dass wir heute in dieser runde zusammen
waren
die minister machte das wort an
premierminister mark rutte
soweit die pressekonferenz von dem
französischen staatspräsidenten manuel
makro dem österreichischen kanzler
sebastian kurz und der deutschen
kanzlerin reden wir darüber mit guido
steinberg das sind ja durchaus spannende
punkte gewesen vor allen dingen der
punkt den der französische präsident
aber auch der österreichische
bundeskanzler aufgebracht haben schengen
da gibt es große lücken und wenn wir
nicht wissen wer im schengen raum ist
wenn sozusagen die außengrenzen des
schengen-raums löchrig sind dann kann
man die sozusagen bewegungsfreiheit im
schengen raum nicht weiterhin so lassen
ist das tatsächlich ein riesiges problem
was über jahre nicht angegangen wurde
ich würde das so sehen und ich denke
auch dass viele in unseren
sicherheitsbehörden das so sehen
und es ist kein zufall dass der
französische präsident dieses thema
aufgebracht hat immerhin hatten wir uns
ja in nizza mit einem hatten täter zu
tun der gerade erst im september über
italien nach frankreich gereist ist
insgesamt ist es so dass die europäische
grenzsicherung bis heute nicht
funktioniert obwohl seit jahren
vielleicht sogar jahrzehnten bekannt ist
dass das ein problem ist und das stimmt
auch optimistisch dass hier zumindest
herr makro und und auch der herr kurz
das thema so konkret aufgegriffen haben
sie haben es schon angesprochen das ist
ja der französische präsident mann
gewesen der gesagt hat das attentat von
nizza zeigt eben missstände auf und ich
meine
deutlicher kann man es nicht sagen dass
wenn die außengrenzen nicht geschützt
werden dann muss man sich überlegen wie
die reisefreiheit aussieht ein anderes
großes thema
das makro angestiftet an angeschnitten
hat das ist die verknüpfung von
datenbanken
ich muss sagen ich erinnere mich daran
dass eigentlich nach jedem anschlag egal
von welcher seite gesagt wird in europa
müssen die sicherheitsbehörden besser
zusammenarbeiten daten austauschen
er hat gesagt das muss in europa besser
flutschen und schneller gehen tut sich
da nichts
seit jahren daran gearbeitet aber das
problem ist natürlich dass die dass die
rechtlichen grundlagen in europa
insgesamt nicht übereinstimmen
wir haben da jetzt drei staaten die
vertreten waren also frankreich
österreich und deutschland und da können
die die regeln gar nicht
unterschiedlicher sein wir haben ein
land frankreich das letzten endes wenn
es um eine effektive
terrorismusbekämpfung geht alles möglich
macht und wir haben zwei andere länder
die trotz der bedrohung in den letzten
jahren doch sehr sehr liberal geblieben
sind deutschland insbesondere hält den
datenschutz weiterhin hoch und es
erfordert es übersteigt so ein bisschen
meine fantasie jemand all dieser
europäischen systeme
denn miteinander verknüpfen will
der große das große problem der
europäischen terrorismusbekämpfung ist
ganz einfach dass wir aufgrund sehr
unterschiedlicher politischer kulturen
ganz ganz unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen haben und gerade
frankreich und deutschland sind da kaum
kompatibel
es ist vielleicht auch auffällig dass
die kanzlerin die deutsche
regierungschefin mit keiner silbe etwas
von datenaustausch et cetera gesagt hat
sondern insofern nur zugestimmt hat
ihren vorrednern mack und kurz das beim
entry exit system also bei dem wissen
wer im schengen raum ist etwas dringend
getan werden muss kommen wir zu einem
anderen punkt den der österreichische
kanzler angesprochen hatte und der ja
irgendwie offensichtlich ist wenn wir an
die vergangenen attentate zurückdenken
da sind ja zwei menschen aus dem
gefängnis entlassen worden und haben
dann zugeschlagen
sebastian kurz hat gesagt die masse von
menschen in gefängnissen die als kämpfer
in syrien waren oder es versucht haben
da hinzukommen die werden ja auch
irgendwann freigelassen das sind
tickende zeitbomben sehen sie auch diese
große gefahren
nun wir hatten es ja tatsächlich in
dresden und österreich mit zwei solchen
fällen zu tun und der österreichische
kanzler hat das hier sehr sehr pointiert
formuliert aber ich glaube dass er da
recht hat und das große problem wird in
den nächsten jahren sein dass hunderte
vielleicht sogar tausende ehemalige
dschihadisten freikommen
und dass dann die große kunst ist
herauszufinden wer von denen vielleicht
noch gefährlich ist die deutschen
versuchen das vor allem damit zu lösen
dass sie sehr sehr viel abschieben sehr
viel sehr viel mehr als in der
vergangenheit aber die letzten fälle
zeigen dass das die sicherheitslage
nicht unbedingt verbessert es geht
tatsächlich darum herauszufinden wie man
denn mit gefährdern umgeht die aus dem
gefängnis freigelassen werden das ist
einmal ein rechtliches problem auf
welcher grundlage will man die
observieren dann aber vor allem ein
personelles problem sicherheitsbehörden
können diese große zahl von gefährlichen
personen und wir müssen ja auch noch die
nazis und die linksextremisten mit
berücksichtigen die ja auch überwacht
werden wollen
kaum zu das ist kaum zu leisten
da haben wir die aktuelle information
unions fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus hat
heute auch noch mal zu dem thema sich
geäußert und hatte eine zahl ja auch mal
genannt derzeit zählen die deutschen
nachrichtendienste rund 620
islamistische gefährder wie eben damit
umgehen das ist eben eine große frage
man kann eben wahrscheinlich nicht
hinter jedem zwei polizisten stellen
oder sozusagen verfassungsschützer die
das ganze dann beobachten richtig ja das
ist richtig wenn es denn 22 polizisten
oder nachrichtendienst lavieren wäre das
vielleicht noch zu leisten aber sie
brauchen für eine vollständige operation
24 stunden am tag etwas mehr als 30
personen vom geld will ich da gar nicht
reden dass das kostet und in einer stadt
wie berlin haben wir bei über 80
islamistischen gefährdern vielleicht ein
oder zwei die tatsächlich gleichzeitig
intensiv observiert werden
das zeigt so ein bisschen das ausmaß des
problems und die äußerungen von herrn
kurz die zeigt dass zumindest die
österreicher wohl überlegen was es da
für weitere maßnahmen geben kann
vielleicht so wie ich die österreicher
kenne denken sie da über eine
verlängerte abschiebehaft vielleicht
sogar über eine art von
administrativhaft nach israelischem
vorbild nach aber ich denke dass das in
europa für große kontroversen sorgen
wird wir haben mehrfach die frage über
facebook eben auch bekommen warum die
ausbildung von imamen so wichtig ist
also erst mal her mit weiteren fragen so
konkret und sie ist ja berechtigt denn
sebastian kurz der österreichische
kanzler hat ja genau das auch
angesprochen die ausbildung von imamen
denn er sagt hinter dem terror da gibt
es ja eine gewisse basis was meint er
damit warum ist die ausbildung so
wichtig ja der der österreichische
bundeskanzler der rede tatsächlich
überall etwas anderes phänomen die
österreicher haben einen ganz anderen
ansatz der vor allem darauf abzielt
nicht nur den dschihadistischen und den
salafistischen bereich auszutrocknen
sondern sie greifen auch sogenannte
moderat islamistische bewegungen an
wir haben das erst bei der jüngsten
durchsuchungen gesehen die höchste
reicher wollen tatsächlich die
muslimbruderschaft unter druck setzen
das ziel ist so wie es scheint eine eine
ganz breite bekämpfung des politischen
islam wie sie in deutschland aus meiner
sicht ganz undenkbar ist und das ist er
das ist der wesen das ist der
wesentliche unterschied letzten endes
geht es allerdings aus meiner sicht
zunächst einmal darum zu identifizieren
welche moscheen denn überhaupt
gefährlich sind und da gehen die
österreicher aus meiner sicht ein ein
bisschen zu weit die deutschen
die haben da ein etwa er kooperativen
ansatz gewählt sie setzen vor allem
darauf dass man mit den moderaten
islamisten oder mit den konservativen
muslimen zusammen arbeitet um damit
gegengewichte zu bilden
das ist ein ganz wichtiger unterschied
in den beiden ansätzen sebastian kurz
der österreichische kanzler hat es ja
aber auch selbst gesagt die
radikalisierung findet ja nicht nur in
hinterzimmern oder in einer moschee
statt sondern eben jetzt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert vor allen
dingen im internet und das ist natürlich
auch sehr schwer da das ganze in den
griff zu bekommen wir bekommen weitere
fragen was zur eu strategie sozusagen
über youtube erreicht uns die frage wäre
eine eu-behörde wie das fbi oder die ce
auf eu-ebene machbar da kommen wir noch
mal zu dem punkt des gemeinsamen
agierens auf eu ebene
nein auf gar keinen fall
man sieht dass in den letzten jahren
immer wieder die tätigkeit von diensten
und polizei in der terrorismusbekämpfung
die gehört zum kernbereich staatlicher
souveränität und besonders diejenigen
staaten in europa die da gut aufgestellt
sind wie vor allem frankreich oder
zumindest besser als die kleinen staaten
wie deutschland die werden nicht bereit
sein souveränität an europa abzugeben
darüber hinaus ist es aus meiner sicht
auch nicht das problem das problem ist
zunächst einmal die
terrorismusbekämpfung in einzelnen
staaten effektiver zu gestalten ganz
einfach deshalb weil wir hinter staaten
wie frankreich oder großbritannien wenn
wir die noch dazu zählen wollen doch
weit hier hinken die österreicher die
deutschen die niederlande aber auch
dänemark die sind so viel liberaler dass
da zunächst einmal einiges getan werden
muss bis man überhaupt mit staaten wie
frankreich zusammenarbeiten kann also
eine europäische lösung sehe ich da
tatsächlich nicht bis auf die geno wie
in europäischen fragen wie zb die
grenzsicherung bei der ja dringend etwas
getan werden muss
eine insofern können wir noch ein
bisschen auf das thema internet zurück
ich habe es eben schon gesagt sebastian
kurz österreichische kanzler meinte es
ist schwierig mit dem internet
radikalisierung ist dort eben meistens
der ort wo das ganze stattfindet
der französische präsident jacques rogge
ist sozusagen auch darauf eingegangen
hat gesagt man muss entschlossen gegen
terroristische propaganda vorgehen das
internet das sei sicherlich ein raum der
freiheit aber es darf nicht missbraucht
werden es dürfe kein schlupfwinkel sein
und er sagte dass das ziel sei ablösung
von terroristischen inhalt innerhalb von
einer stunde für wie realistisch halten
sie das da muss ich gestehen da bin ich
mir nicht sicher wie realistisch das ist
da bin ich sehr gespannt darauf wie
diese vorschläge denn dann konkret
umgesetzt werden sollen aber der ansatz
ist richtig wir haben es tatsächlich in
den letzten jahren nicht mehr so sehr
mit den radikalen moscheen zu tun viele
von denen sind geschlossen
viele imame sind auch im gefängnis
andere sind nach syrien gegangen und
dort verschwunden
es ist tatsächlich das internet über das
die ideologie verbreitet wird aber bei
der schließung muss man immer daran
denken dass das bevorzugte
kommunikationsinstrument der
dschihadisten heute telegramm ist und
wenn sie dann sehen dass sie wie in
einem land wie österreich whatsapp
beispielsweise überhaupt nicht überwacht
werden kann
dann zeigt das die probleme auf sie
können natürlich fixe webseiten stören
oder auch einige soziale medien die er
öffentlich unterwegs sind aber die
wirklich geschützten seiten auf
telegramm die sind ein ganz ganz anderes
thema und darum muss es eigentlich gehen
wie länder wie österreich oder auch
deutschland und andere kleine
europäische staaten in diese kopierten
also die geschützten bereiche des netzes
gelangen dazu haben wir heute wiederum
nichts gehört
es ist sozusagen das internet imame
radikalisierung im gefängnis das eine es
gibt aber natürlich auch eine ja wie
soll man sagen anstachelung auf der
ganze öffentliche art und weise auslöser
der anschläge in den letzten wochen sind
ja auch die mohammed-karikaturen gewesen
und da hat der türkische präsident
erdogan ja ordentlich öl ins feuer
geschüttet sozusagen stark kritisiert
quasi die stimmung angeheizt zum boykott
französisch
so waren aufgefordert den französischen
staatspräsidenten marc raum beschimpft
wie sehen sie das ganze wenn erdogan
sich hier sozusagen hervortut in der
kritik und mehr die mohammed-karikaturen
kritisiert aber nicht die enthauptung
eines französischen lehrer ja also die
tatsache dass er tatsächlich nur wie die
karikaturen und nicht über den mord
gesprochen hat kam eine ermutigung von
attentätern gleich allerdings gibt es
keine hinweise darauf dass irgendeine
der täter in frankreich österreich oder
deutschland auf den türkischen
präsidenten gehört hat das verhalten der
türkischen regierung wirft meines
erachtens aber ein schlaglicht auf ein
großes problem
wir haben nämlich einen großen bereich
also ein großes spektrum an islamisten
in all diesen drei ländern die nicht
gewalttätig sind die aber ein
gemeinsames thema mit den dschihadisten
haben beispielsweise in den mohammed
karikaturen die österreicher nehmen das
zum anlass um sich auch den moderat
islamistischen oder den nicht
gewalttätig islamistischen bereich
vorzunehmen und tatsächlich teils auch
zu verfolgen
die anderen europäischen staaten sind da
bisher noch vorsichtiger es ist aus
meiner sicht zu fragen ob da ein trend
vorliegt ich persönlich bin der meinung
dass man mit den staatlichen türkischen
stellen die in der religionspolitik in
deutschland eine rolle spielen durchaus
anders umgehen sollte als das bisher der
fall war die äußerungen von herrn
erdogan zeigen dass zumindest in der
gegenwärtigen phase türkische staatliche
behörden kein partner in der
religionspolitik und schon gar nicht in
der terrorismusbekämpfung sein können
erst einmal ganz zum abschluss eine
frage die sich irgendwie aus diesem
heutigen tag zusammen ergibt wenn man
einerseits sieht dass die staats und
regierungschefs beraten was man tun kann
wenn man auf der anderen seite auch
heute noch mal an die anschläge zurück
denkt eigentlich zusammenfassen die
frage von johanna scheiber über facebook
müssen wir denn jetzt in deutschland
damit rechnen dass auch hier islamisten
mehr anschläge verüben
oder würden sie sagen die tatsache dass
auf höchster ebene europa sich
zusammenrauft um den terrorismus zu
bekämpfen
dass das uns sozusagen sicherheit geben
kann ich glaube dass einige der
wichtigsten fragen angesprochen wurden
grenzsicherung beispielsweise
verbreitung der ideologie und es wurde
zumindest eine debatte begonnen über die
frage welche islamisten müssen wir denn
eigentlich bekämpfen wie weit müssen wir
gehen so weit wie die österreicher oder
bleiben wir so liberal wie die deutschen
also das sind alles positive aspekte wir
dürfen aber nicht vergessen dass es
nicht nur die maßnahmen der europäer
waren in den letzten jahren die dazu
geführt haben dass wir sicherer sind es
ist vor allem die schwäche des
islamischen staates in syrien im irak in
anderen ländern die dazu beigetragen hat
dass diese organisation keine attentate
mehr verüben konnte und das verdanken
wir vor allem der terrorismusbekämpfung
der amerikaner und beispielsweise der
syrischen kurden staaten wie die türkei
da waren da eher hinderlich und ich
glaube dass wir uns bewusst sein sollten
dass es viele äußere faktoren sind und
dass wir wenn wir dieses phänomen
bekämpfen wollen uns nicht nur auf das
inland beschränken dürfen sondern auch
schauen müssen was ist dem nahen osten
los und wie sichern wir uns die
partnerschaft der amerikaner auch
längerfristig sind letzten endes die usa
die uns den es in den letzten jahren vom
hals geschafft haben auch wenn wir das
der regierung trump ungerne ungerne
positiv anrechnen
herr steinberg dann ganz herzlichen dank
viele fragen die wir gestellt haben
viele fragen die sie beantwortet haben
an diesem tag wo es eben um das thema
ging gemeinsam gegen den terrorismus
vielen dank herr steinberg ja das war
unser zdf heute live zur konferenz zur
virtuellen konferenz zwischen den staats
und regierungschefs merkel kurz und max
zusammen mit der eu-spitze eben über die
suche nach einer strategie
maßnahmen im kampf gegen den
islamistischen terror recht herzlichen
dank für ihr interesse
schuss und auf wiedersehen